after more than a year of living with
covet 19
safety precautions quarantines and
social isolation
life is starting to return back to
pre-covert normal
and that's forcing our brains to rethink
how we behave socially
now we have to make individual decisions
about what are environments in which we
feel comfortable and what are
environments where we don't feel
comfortable
should i eat indoors go to that concert
wear my mask
a new mental toll is emerging many
people
are reevaluating the habits they formed
during the pandemic
and reassessing how safe it is to resume
once normal activities
but why do some of us find it difficult
to make these choices
it has to do with how our brains process
information
let's take a look at what happens when
you're finally reunited with friends
and you're faced with a choice
mia is in her 40s healthy fully
vaccinated
and is attending a backyard barbecue
party but it starts to rain
and the party moves indoors those cdc
guidelines say the risk of infection is
minimal for people like mia who are
fully vaccinated she has to decide
whether she feels comfortable
going indoors with a big group of people
when we're making those decisions in our
brains what we're really doing is
weighing three sets of factors
the first factor is almost the easiest
to understand and that's
what risks am i willing to take when i
understand the risks completely
making a choice can happen quickly as
several parts of the brain work together
to come to a decision
when people begin to move indoors mia
faces a known risk
the chance she could get exposed to
covet 19. her prefrontal cortex
starts to assess that risk and the
possible outcomes of her actions
the second is uncertainty aversion
things that are ambiguous and obscure
that assessment happens in part in the
amygdala which is associated with
processing fear
distress or anxiety the more ambiguous a
situation is
the more likely someone is to be
cautious for mia
the ambiguous risk is tied to how much
she doesn't know
is everyone vaccinated how high are
infection rates in town
is there enough ventilation in the house
if she has a good handle
on all this information her ambiguous
risk is lower
and she may often favor of the reward to
go inside and continue spending time
with her friends
the third factor is the habit system
that's located in the dorsal striatum
near the amygdala when we come into an
environment that we've been to a million
times before the pandemic
and we have some set of behaviors that
we've learned to produce in those
environments
like walking up to someone and hugging
them these
habits are going to also influence our
behavior prior to the pandemic
mia used to hang out at her friend's
homes regularly
but coved changed a lot of her habits
she only saw people outdoors
in each of these brain areas there are
millions of brain cells and those brain
cells
generate action potentials these little
electrochemical impulses
with which they send information from
one part of the brain to another
so as mia weighs her choice the brain is
calculating the risk and reward
of going inside versus going home
in the final stage of decision making
information from multiple parts of the
brain is integrated to make a final
choice
this includes the prefrontal cortex at
the very front of the brain
and the ventral striatum and neighboring
region to the dorsal striatum and
amygdala
so there is where we find groups of
nerve cells
that represent each of the options and
have aggregated together
all of the different factors that are
going to influence how much you like or
don't like doing that
and then in these areas in areas closely
associated with them
that's where we expect to see this
competition where the
group of cells that is most active the
ones that are encoding the more
desirable option
with greater electrochemical activity
will sort of take control
and lead us to the behavior that we've
chosen to make
but we're all different our
personalities age and life experiences
influence all three systems uniquely so
what mia decides
could be different from her friend mark
some of us are more concerned about
ambiguity maybe because of prior life
trauma
some of us are more concerned about risk
and some of us
are more driven by habits so there are
individual differences in the way we
weigh each of these three sets of
factors
and then of course we all have different
inputs from the world around us
another factor that can influence our
decisions over the next few months
may be related to trauma from the
pandemic dr glimtra is actively studying
how the events of the last year can
affect our choices
he says there's still a lot of unknowns
but
we do know that while trauma changes the
way people decide
and changes the way people behave it
makes them more ambiguity adverse for
example
it doesn't completely disorder the brain
the basic rules and structures for
making decisions remain the same
it's the weightings that are different
so for mark who lost his grandfather to
copen19
the decision of whether to stay or leave
the party could be weighted differently
due to that trauma
as the pandemic eases in many parts of
the world
it's unclear how trauma and fear
associated with the past year
will continue to impact people's lives
but the brain is flexible
it constantly learns from experience and
as we're testing our boundaries of what
feels safe and what doesn't we're
learning to adjust to all situations
that now feel new
it's that learning that will ultimately
help us get back
to a new normal
you